hey hey I've been thinking about this
whole situation
alright good cuz I don't really
understand what the prosecution no not
the case but this this situation the
Blues the grays little it's drab what
can we do to spruce up this place you
know it's prison
there's no sprucing up what a negative
Nancy okay I'm not a negative Nancy I'm
just the one who's stuck in prison look
one you're in a tropical paradise the
hell you doin come smoked legal
marijuana next to a steel drum doesn't
this cheer you up being outside of a
prison drawings drawings are supposed to
cheer me up you haven't let me finish
here's a big booty I'm good for you she
brings you [ __ ] martini in the day this
doesn't help this does not help are you
more of an island no no now what I'm at
won't you help me with rock cocoa butter
wherever you see fit
nope huh good job it's not nope not
helping you don't feel like you're on
vacation right now no I don't I feel
like I'm still in prison and my lawyers
around does not help okay sorry
my trees bye beautiful ocean by a woman
with dick there's a lot of other things
we can do yeah can we work on my case no
but how about look you're on a farm
put the wait in the silo it's a long
winter and there's a friendly cow look
say hi to the cow I'm not saying hi to
the cow but he'll say hi to you the only
way he knows how
mmm-hmm ticket doesn't even look like
it's backwards on this side I can't read
it it says oom baby he's meditating can
we please talk can we please talk about
I don't want to be on a farm I want to
be out of prison technically a farm
would be at a prison you know worried
okay okay okay okay I think the best way
for you and I to discuss your case at
this juncture is via hangman I'm not
don't move
don't move there you go you go first not
playing hangman I'll go first
is there an H there is is there a P
there is is the word whoops
it is alright what is that what is that
what does that mean what does whoops
it means whoops I forgot to file your
appeal coz I was too busy learning basic
cartooning whoops I'm screwed
I'm screwed oh oh I'm sorry hey hey
don't don't be sad it's a little hard
not to be I think I can help
yeah girl doesn't that just feel better
huh now it just looks like you have a
unibrow I'm sad
hmm oh oh and I have boobs
hubba-hubba Hong Kong Hong Kong